and it is jesus lozardo and yes he has
the outstanding fans boys making his
sick start let's hope that lizardo today
back in the homecon finds that he can uh
do something special in the start
against the orders today two out runner
at first top of the first no score
swing we're gonna miss by franco and
that will do it the orioles failed to
score with the a's coming up in the
bottom half five starts two in one
record he's won his last two starts era
at 4.2 love that bottom line 21
punch-outs only six walks opponents
hitting 265 off the right-hander matt
harvey comes the tenth pitch
right back to harvey
fires to first and he gets him hopefully
it didn't get him on the hand it looked
like he was able to knock it down he
throws out chapman the inning is finally
over and will go to the second in a
scoreless game
three and two marius the runner not
going and that pitch is low and the
bases are loaded with noel but he had
air a single and now a wall so a bunch
of trouble here for lizardo austin hayes
digs in the one-two pitcher the base is
loaded and this one's ground to the left
side it's throw for a base hit stort
will score remote urease being sent
plate the plate is cut off urea scores
and then the ball is thrown away down
the left field line another orioles run
will score and all the way to third base
goes austin hayes a bases clearing
single
plus an error and it's three nothing
baltimore well austin hayes was moved
into the number two spot brandon hyde
told us
because he could create action
this is action created and action
personified just great
button pushing base run and now mancini
there's still nobody out and three runs
in for baltimore mancini had two balls
in the strike
bat
off let's see is this going to fall in
andres can't hang on
and the orioles have another run as
austin hayes scores
well that'll be a base hit tough play
andrus got the glove on it but couldn't
bring it in and the orioles lead is now
four nothing wow
this is an oakland age defense it's been
really good this year
tied with the orioles for third best in
the american league and fielding
percentage but defensively they have not
gotten it done here in the top of the
third this is a tough chance but a ball
that i think probably should have been
caught and the orioles have scored again
the a's have the infield in
and andrews could not make the willy
mayes style catch lizardo delivers full
counts and this one's hit to right field
and it's deep back goes kenna he makes a
terrific catch on the warning track and
slams into the wall it will be a
sacrifice fly from mount castle as
mancini scores
its five-nothing orioles
and after all the
bad defense for oakland in this third
mark canada just made a terrific play
robbing mount castle of two rbis and
extra bases and the great effort by mark
hanna to track that ball down tremendous
play and especially because mark has
played primarily in left field this year
and he can play everywhere and he's
played center and just great recognition
of how far he had to go where he was in
relation to the wall and great play over
the shoulder well ryan got robbed but he
didn't totally get robbed with that at
bat because it is an rbi for him and
there's a wild pitch that'll score
another one
he's in safe
bronco comes hobbling out of there but
the wild pitch in the oriole lead is now
a touchdown six nothing wow runs have
been so hard to come by for the orioles
as of late and it's the ball just right
off the glove of garcia there's the
slide just in time by franco it has been
a super sloppy inning of defense for the
open ace but you know what give credit
to the orioles too because they have
taken advantage of every one of those
mishaps so guerra's second appearance in
as many days he worked a uh sixth inning
in relief of mike fire seventh inning
relief for mike fires last night one two
three a couple of k's
two pitch swings
he's [ __ ] up
so two outs here in the top of the
fourth
we like to see this from guerra here
just kind of deleting the last outing
that he had in baltimore things didn't
go quite well for him which is rear and
back or challenge heater in the zone
he'll take it
2-2
this one is fair backhanded
and they get the speedy mullet so brown
with a nice play garrett covering
quickly we have reached the top of the
sixth inning orioles six a's nothing jb
when delkin comes in his 15th appearance
does not have a record 3.180 all right
boy this is the guy you'd like to see
get going for the orioles remember what
he did last year in a short amount of
time he gets starts hitting those home
runs he can hit him in bunches
right field deep down into the corner
canna on the run he won't get there it's
gone
d.j stewart
a two-run shot
and the orioles now lead it
eight to nothing well ben you said
when he gets him going
look out well that's how you bust out of
an ofer kind of a one-hander right over
his last 18 but nobody's going to
remember that they're going to remember
this bomb a two-run shot for d.j stewart
his second home run of the year drives
in his seventh run and recognizing his
change up body gets a little out in
front but you know what he keeps his
hands back he sinks down into his legs
watch him sink right there and go get
that ball
boy he knew it he posed on it just
barrels it up right down the right field
line almost exactly where cedric mullins
hit his home run last night orioles up
eight to nothing now here in the top of
the sixth
see if there's a play garcia
maybe
and i think he caught it
gibson says yes he did
or not well he's definitely the first
base umpire junior valentine is coming
over and saying that it hit the net
gibson was there
doesn't mean valentine did not have a
good look at it it did not hit the neck
looked like it hit the net there yeah
did not hit the net well and you can see
garcia's got his glove positioned where
that that would be blocking the net off
yeah right there you see that glove hit
the net this is maybe your best look
because it's right there never hit the
net so the call is overturned and the
orioles get two more on dj stewart's two
run homer bottom of the six coming up
and that'll bring up seth brown who has
hit a couple of fly balls in this
round smokes one and that's fair down
the right field line
chapman digging for third kansai is
going to wave him home
he's going to score
nbas are on the board seth brown has
himself an rbi double here in the bottom
of the sixth pitching change for the
orioles salsa has what they call in
baseball reverse splits i mean he's a
right-hander but he's really good
against left-handed hitters
this could be a hit though and it will
be a hit
it's gonna knock it around as brown
comes in the score so
salsa gives up a hit to a left-handed
hitter for the first time this year and
now it's eight to two what a story this
would be
mark is singled walked and he is fly to
center
down the left field line
toward the corner and that baby is gone
a high towering drive just inside the
foul pole for cannon and that is his
fourth home run of the year i was
leaning as much as i could trying to
bring it back
canada supplied the power
but i thought he got out just a little
bit too far in front going to stay true
right down the line it's number four for
canna one on one out
right field
near the bullpen look out oh dj stewart
wow hangs on but wrapped his head wow
hope he's all right i'm talking about
face first head first oh
grabbing the jaw he says stay stay where
you are i'm i'm okay he said brian ebel
i'm good i'll pop my jaw back in the
into place and i'll be fine wow i might
run right through there there's a little
bit of padding i'm not sure if he hit
the padding or the top of that bullpen
roof but we're fixing to see goes a long
way he's running wide open you could
tell right there he was not going to
check up catches it and right into the
side of that corner head first and thank
gosh he does hit the padding but i'm
sure behind that padding oh yeah that
could have been nasty bottom of the
ninth inning orioles have an 8-3 lead in
oakland looking for a third straight win
overall pitch by tate to mariano ramon
it's a deep drive left center field
hayes going back at the track he will
turn and watch it fly
and lauriano is hitting out
his fourth home run
it's now eight to four of baltimore if
handed hitting mitch moreland steps in
this should do it cedric mullins waiting
catching and the orioles get a win 8-4
the final score and they win this
three-game series taking the first two